Hello and welcome the fire of learning.
We've talked about the
Viking age somewhat in depth,
more in depth I would say than many
channels on youtube seem to go,
but in this video we're going to finish
it off and talk about the end of the
Viking age.
So what caused the end of the Viking age
and what does the end of the Viking age
really refer to?
Well,
many people put the end of the Viking
age in the 11th century. After his time,
a number of things were happening.
Firstly,
Scandinavia was becoming
more politically centralized.
It's here that we really begin to see
the beginnings of the modern Scandinavian
nations.
A main source of whacking opportunity
to go rating was the weather class
structure was structured.
It was a greater emphasis on democracy
and really less of an emphasis on having
single unquestionable leaders.
There's a story in fact of the Vikings
in France being asked to identify their
leader to which they're applied.
We are all leaders here. Later on,
that all changed. The wealthy
elite all moved higher at the top.
The governments became more centralized
and encompass more territory.
In the former Viking homelands began
to resemble other European nations.
Secondly,
the north were becoming Christians.
Remember that life Erickson had been sent
to spread Christianity as far away as
Greenland and therefore the
urge to resist the Christians,
which was believed to be a major cause
for the Viking age itself was less
intense.
In the 10th Century,
Harold Bluetooth convinced a Danish to
convert to Christianity and all off the
first and second of Norway, but brought
Christianity to their nations as well.
Story sometimes tell if people
demanding that a trial be conducted,
that pagans would light one fire and
Christians would light another fire and a
buzzer.
Kirra kind of slightly insane Viking
warrior known for working themselves up
into a terrible rage before battle,
possibly with the help
of psychedelic mushrooms.
What attempt to pass through each fire
in whichever fire he could not pass
through was the one which
belonged to the Sherwood legend.
According to legend and one such events,
he passed to the peg and fire with these
but could not pass to the Christians
fire. Many norths were then
convinced of Christianity,
civil war emerge and part of Sweden.
Over the religion,
pagans and Christians took
up arms against each other.
Though by the 12th century,
the people of Modern Sweden had accepted
Christianity as well. Furthermore,
if Viking explorations sort of slowed
down at this time to a viking set,
the Faroe Islands and Iceland
and Greenland in North America,
but around a thousand and they got kicked
out of North America and after that in
North America was just a mysterious land
that they had sent lumberjacks to for
what and they stopped colonizing
these distant lands. Oh, very likely.
Make a video and the near future of
what might've happened in an alternate
history where the Vikings continued
colonization of American successful
successfully,
the colony in Greenland as well,
would eventually fail
over hundreds of years.
Green and lost contact with the
rest of Europe. The climate change,
the growing Calder and hostile native
Americans that throw people also moved
into the region.
A variety of factors is a very
likely contributed to the mysterious
disappearance of the north of Greenland.
By the 15th century,
the colonies were likely
entirely abandoned.
Europe itself was changing in ways that
made viking raise less feasible as well.
European nations like England and France
were becoming more centralized to and
they were beginning to maintain
standing professional armies,
kings of these nations.
Quite simply,
we're tired of the vikings and Delta
fences around formerly vulnerable targets.
Viking Raiders who specialize
in shock tag like soon,
found defenses and standing armies in
the way of their treasure making the past
time considerably unappealing.
The Viking Age,
quite obviously it was coming to an end
at the influence of the Norsemen was
fading. However, one
Norseman Harold Hardrada,
King of Norway was not
going down without a fight.
King Harold to try for some
time to invade Denmark.
Though he eventually signed a
truce agreeing to not invade them.
He then turned his attention
toward England where the
monarchy of the day in law
was in trouble. He claimed the throne
from himself upon the death of Edward,
the confessor the throne.
However, it did not go to him.
It went to another Harold King,
Harold Godwinson and Anglo Saxon last
Anglo Saxon too. We have a rural England,
in fact,
Hardrada dreaming of empire,
thus set sail to invade England
and claim the throne for himself.
In the year 10 66 Hardrada invaded.
Though this invasion was a failure.
He had arrogantly assume that England
had belonged to term and that resistance
would soon fall apart and not the battle
of Stamford Bridge for which she was
very unprepared.
He was defeated by an English army.
An arrow struck our drought
as throat killing him,
and subsequently many historians say
ending the Viking Age within the next 200
years of vikings would be kicked
out of Ireland and Scotland as well.
The Normans would assimilate to the
rest of France and Russia would become a
primarily Slovic nation. Liking a
settlement and exploration had ceased.
Their empires had been repelled.
The raids had stops. Their religion,
culture and society has had assimilated
largely to the rest of Europe.
The Viking age was over.
This is by no means though means
they're influenced or that the north's
themselves had disappeared.
Quite notably,
only three days after Harold had drawn a
died in England. William the conqueror,
King of Normandy, set out to
conquer England. Of course,
remember Normandy was the land that the
king of France gave the Vikings over a
hundred years earlier.
Many people attribute the Norman Conquest
to being a conquest of the French,
but in fact they were French Viking.
His invasion was successful and
its affects last to this day,
and that is only one example of how the
north and the Viking age in general help
shaped modern Europe.
The Viking societies themselves would
evolve into modern day Denmark, Sweden,
and Norway.
They're calling either the well became
the modern nations of Iceland and the
Pharaoh islands. Furthermore,
they linguistically,
culturally and politically
influenced England, France, Russia,
and the Baltic states, as well as
other places as well. So in summary,
it's entirely justifiable to have mixed
feelings regarding the vikings by our
own standards today. They were in some
ways abhorrent and awful. People there.
Infanticide, murder, rape, pillaging,
and general destruction is
justification to hate them really,
and be glad that they
are a thing of the past.
But other than Norris around at the time,
who developed a rich,
somewhat democratic culture and society
who set out to build better lives for
themselves and explore new lands and
to impact of the world in many positive
ways are entirely worthy of being
as admirable ancestors of the West.
We can look at the men of women who moved
to unforgiving and unknown frontiers
like the Faroe Islands, Iceland,
Greenland in North America,
and perhaps draw inspiration
from them as we are ourselves.
Begin to look toward the
unforgiving frontiers of the
solar system, for example.
And that's all I have
for the Vikings for now.
For more videos and series of
videos on subjects like history,
as well as a variety of other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of
learning and subscribe. Thank you.
Or as a north would say, fuck
of fear. Rare for watching.
Oh, by the way, I forgot
to mention Vikings,
then an accident where horns on
their helmets. That's a myth.